overseas now there's an increase in
violence in afghanistan as u.s
troops are pulling out of a major base
in volatile helmand province
taliban insurgents capture a district in
the north just in the past few days
tonight we look at how the american exit
is affecting afghan nationals who've
assisted the u.s
and were promised special immigrant
visas
national security correspondent jennifer
griffin tells us the future for them
could be bleak their lives are in
extreme danger for seven years ishmael
khan risked his life as a combat
translator for the u.s special forces in
eastern afghanistan
now he is safely working in seattle but
has this warning for the biden
administration
about what the taliban will do to the
seventeen thousand
others like him it will go after every
single
uh translator khan's story was
immortalized in the book american
spartan about his boss the legendary
green beret
major jim gantt the taliban went after
khan's family for working with the u.s
one of my nephew was kidnapped
he was about 10 years old khan says u.s
troops called him their secret weapon
americans are nothing without the
translator
it's their mouth it's their ears their
eyes if they leave them behind
they're gonna die most of them are gonna
die chase milsap served three tours in
iraq as a marine captain
and spent five years trying to bring his
iraqi counterpart
who faced death threats from isis to the
u.s when you work with the americans you
put on our uniform
you know that's a mark for you and your
life gets exponentially dangerous
milsap worries about the guilt u.s
troops will feel if the state department
abandons these translators
i bet you that there are veterans out
there right now who are terrified
and really nervous about whether or not
their interpreters are going to make it
out
the pentagon says the defense secretary
wants to help
he is very supportive of
the president's desire and the state
department's efforts
to expand and to accelerate
the special immigrant visa program uh so
that we can
we can do right by these individuals
congress is getting impatient
if we do not give them uh special
immigrant visas
they will be left behind and be
slaughtered by the enemy
they're being hunted down right now as
we speak they are reaching out to me
these interpreters
in a panic the national security council
held a deputies meeting on the issue
but no decisions have been made as of
yet brett
jennifer griffin at the pentagon
jennifer thank you